fraction of those considered most
vulnerable to infection
and they live on a continent where just
1.5 percent
have been protected yet donations from
the world's wealthiest nations
are now trickling in today the uk said
it would supply
800 000 doses to kenya as part of a
tranche
of 9 million jabs we won't be safe in
the uk until everyone is safe around the
world
but it's also in our direct interest in
terms of opening up the economy opening
up international travel and making sure
we don't see
fifth sixth waves of this virus or its
variance
moral interest and self-interest at work
as boris johnson and kenyan president
uhuru kenyatta
top trade investment and vaccines in the
garden at checkers
the prime minister promised to send 400
000 jabs
this week but kenya like the rest of
africa
needs tens of millions of vaccines the
world health organization's kovacs
facility
ground to a halt last month leaving
officials
in an impossible spot the head of
vaccinations in kenya telling us
his program was running on fumes as of
today
in kenya we have received 1.733 million
doses
of astrazeneca and we have actually
vaccinated about 1.7 million people
so today even as the uk was making the
announcement
we had less than 30 000 doses and and
and
yet the demand is very very high well
that is a nerve-wracking way to run a
national vaccination campaign
yes oh it's nerve-wracking of course
it's it's experience but
it's from some circumstances that we
learn a lot
in africa they've learned they have to
start making vaccines
in africa otherwise wealthier countries
buy up the stock and here in south
africa
two factories will now start to make
these vaccines in fact
one has already started and what's
probably the best way
to overturn these global inequities
it's said that you have to have a
tragedy first
you know uh for things to really happen
but i think you know in a nutshell
that's why we need more capacity
it's a start but health officials need
1.5 billion doses
to inoculate 60 percent of the african
population
a task and a challenge that will take
years
john sparks sky news